foreign
Santa Barbara hi Emily welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey what's up
I have a question about what I should do
well me and my husband should do with
our year-end bonus uh because we're we
can't go exactly in the baby steps
because we already own a home we bought
it pre-days but besides that we are debt
free the baby step the home home is in
the baby steps maybe step six
you're saying you bought a house before
it was time to in the baby steps is it
paid off
no okay then you have the regular baby
steps where are you in the baby steps
all right so that's paid off so uh
without 34k we can put 5K to finish our
emergency fund so we'll be at 20. so
you're debt-free but the house
yes okay and then you can finish your
emergency fund that's maybe step three
so what yeah so finish it emergency fund
and then we want to put uh max out both
of our Ross 2020 cute so that B12 and
then we're gonna put um
2K for our each of our kids 529s we have
two kids good
um and then we have 15 left so that
would be a thousand per kid and then we
have 15. so we do have a truck that we
want to get up and running so we wanted
to see if that is okay it's an older
truck it's just a hobby it's a classic
old old car uh or should we be throwing
that at the house all right once you get
past baby step three you leave intensity
and move to intentional
okay and uh so if this is intentional
and you say okay we're gonna we're gonna
work on the hobby truck a little bit or
we need to buy a couch or we're going to
go on vacation or we need to buy a new
car because the one we got is a dumpy
one we got to move up a little that's
where this is where you would do all of
that knowing that every dollar you spend
there is not going towards your mortgage
so you're going to be in debt a little
longer but that's okay because it's
intentional versus intensity
okay but you don't do this with the
mindset of oh we're never going to get
our mortgage paid off
no we're gonna get our mortgage paid off
anyway
okay yeah that's really good I think a
lot of times when people start the baby
steps they get so focused on the on
being intense that when you get past
that phase it's kind of hard to leave
that mindset to the side and it's not to
say that you get lackadaisical but you
were never intended to live you know
under the gun for the entire I mean
you're supposed to enjoy some of this
money so it's about being intentional
about it you of your husband have
decided this is what we're gonna do this
is worth the opportunity cost and you've
made that decision together so you're
doing just right yep or it makes you
look and go I'd rather pay off my
mortgage than the truck so maybe it's
trying to get rid of the truck either
one's okay but now it's time to be
intentional not just intense so very
good question Merry Christmas to you
Emily